well today i have a very interesting
video on the prostate and the most
important nutrient
to maintain prostate health now this
topic was inspired by my new favorite
book called soil grass
and cancer
okay this is a book
that i found
uh it was very expensive it's basically
250
dollars i couldn't find any used books
but it's filled with nutritional
information that's just fascinating and
each chapter is very very different so
the last chapter was on insulin which i
did a video on that and then this one
was on the relationship between
zinc and the prostate gland there's some
great data i want to share with you i
think the first thing to talk about is
this big confusion of what the prostate
gland is very few people know what the
prostate gland does
all they know is that as you get older
and enlarges and then it affects your
urination
50 of men over the age of 60
start to get an enlargement of the
prostate gland so what we do know is as
you age the prostate gets larger and
that can affect urination stream flow
libido
retention of urine and your bladder
backup of urine in the kidney
and so i think it's important to
understand a little bit about the
prostate in identifying why this occurs
i mean it's kind of weird that as men
age a high high percentage of them start
developing prostate problems and then
as it gets bigger you're more at risk of
getting prostate cancer but just because
the prostate enlarges doesn't mean
that's cancer so let's first start with
where the prostate is located
there's a little bone in the front part
of your pelvis called the symphysis
pubis and the prostate is right behind
that bone okay and then the prostate
also is just underneath the bladder and
there's a little tube that comes down
from the bladder that this prostate
wraps around and the size of the
prostate would be about equivalent to a
walnut size
so it's not that big but it can get
quite big and then you have the rectum
which is right behind that so that's
where it's located but what does it do
the prostate is about 70
gland
and 30
muscle so it does two things it helps
you secrete a certain fluid which i'm
going to talk about
and it also acts as a pump during
ejaculation so it helps push this fluid
through the tube which is the same tube
is where your urine goes through
and then out of the body now sperm is
created in the testicles okay and it
takes roughly about 60 to 70 days for
sperm to
develop so the sperm travels through
this little tube up into the area of the
prostate where you have
additional glands
that produce fluid
with the fluids of the prostate gland
all mixing together into what's called
semen
and so the purpose of semen is to
fertilize sperm and sperm is basically
just the genetics from a male body which
is then going to join with the genetics
of the ovary to form a human body so to
do that you need something to feed the
sperm which is fructose from the semen
you need certain enzymes to help
penetrate into the uterus lining because
there's mucus there and a lot of other
factors to keep this sperm fertile and
the sperm outside the body can last
roughly about five days so on the other
end in the female you have this egg
which is inactive and it becomes active
once the sperm penetrates so that's a
summary of what the prostate does in
relationship to these other factors now
what's interesting about the prostate
gland in relationship to nutrition
is that it is the
gland that has the highest concentration
of zinc so the prostate has a hundred
times more concentration of zinc than
your blood because if you test your
blood and it's normal with zinc it might
not
tell you what's going on inside the
prostate gland so in this book i want to
mention a couple little points
he's talking about the relationship
between a zinc deficiency and what
happens with the prostate gland
it actually enlarges there is a study
done and i will put some links down
below that shows a normal prostate okay
and the level of zinc that's in it it's
like 744
micrograms and then you have a mild
hypertrophy or enlarged prostate gland
that had a lesser amount of zinc which
is 486
micrograms then they tested people with
chronic prostatitis and that was at
470 micrograms now remember this is all
compared to a normal prostate gland
which has
744
micrograms and then he talks about
prostate and the cancer
related to zinc apparently that level
was actually on average 273
micrograms of
zinc so we have this relationship
between a zinc deficiency
and inflammation in the prostate gland
enlargement of the prostate gland and
susceptibility to getting prostate
cancer very very interesting the other
point i want to bring up about this is
that
you have a very powerful form of
testosterone okay called dht
so
testosterone can convert to dht
with a certain enzyme okay and that's
called 5-alpha reductase and so
there are certain medications that
inhibit that enzyme to help reduce dht
four
now pattern baldness prostate
hypertrophy erectile dysfunction because
too much of that hormone dht
can create
bad effects but what's interesting about
that is zinc is a natural inhibitor of
that enzyme
fascinating and we also know that people
with low testosterone are usually zinc
deficient so zinc is the most important
trace mineral to make sure your
testosterone is high
make sure that the fertility of sperm
is there and to make sure that the size
of the prostate is maintained now it's
going to get more interesting
why would someone be deficient in zinc
that's the big question okay i'm going
to go through the reasons
they don't consume enough red meat now
think about this
what is the big push now with especially
men as they get over the age of 50.
don't consume red meat red meat is bad
well they never differentiate the
quality of red meat okay they lump red
meat into one group they don't
differentiate between processed meats
and grass-fed organic
they just lump it into one big concept
and tell you to get off red meat and
they tell you to lower your cholesterol
foods which happen to be the building
block of testosterone and then what do
they tell you to eat eat plant-based
make sure you're eating enough whole
grains
which is loaded with phytic acid
probably the biggest thing that blocks
your ability to absorb
zinc in fact two billion people on this
planet are deficient in zinc probably
because they're consuming too much
cereal and too many grains okay
now the other interesting thing about
aging is that when you age you lose
the concentration of stomach acids and
we need stomach acid to be able to
absorb this zinc
if you have low stomach acids you're not
going to absorb
zinc not to mention if you're taking an
antacid you're going to be deficient in
zinc if you're taking a diuretic
that medication will deplete you of zinc
if you're taking statins
you'll have significant zinc
deficiencies alcohol is another common
thing that will cause a zinc deficiency
consuming a lot of sugar
will cause a zinc deficiency
eating frequent meals like in snacking
lid at night while you're watching the
tv creates insulin resistance which can
also deplete
zinc and so i'm trying to prove a point
here if you're not consuming enough zinc
that's going to affect your libido your
testosterone
sperm count
the size of your prostate and eventually
your urine flow one of the best sources
of zinc is shellfish as in oysters but
the second best source is red meat and
to be totally transparent i do have a
zinc product it's my trace minerals
product but i'm going to tell you right
now taking zinc is not going to
guarantee any type of cure for enlarged
prostate lower testosterone reducing
your risk of prostate cancer
or anything related to any medical
condition because there are a lot of
other factors involved your diet how
much alcohol you drink how much stress
you go through and a lot of other
factors related to your medications etc
etc all right so now that you know a
little bit more about the relationship
between zinc and your prostate i wanted
you to watch this next video on zinc
which is quite interesting check it out
you